حرب الدبابات الثقيله على خط المواجهه لا
يطرق باب المهادنه احد كما يبدو خلال
الحرب المستعره بين روسيا واوكرانيا بمعيه
حلفائها الغربيين بحسب موقع ديرشبيل
الشهير وقناه ان تي في الاخباريه فان
المستشاره اولف جونز قد وافق على تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات اليوبارد القتاليه
معلومات تؤكدها في تغريده على تويتر نائبه
رئيس برلمان المانيا التي وصف وزير الدفاع
روسيا بالعدو
المستفزربه العطوانيه والاستفزازيه
والوحشيه والامبرياليه ضد اوكرانيا
طرفا في الحرب
النوعي جاء خلال اجتماع رمشتاين الاخير مع
وعود الكثير من الدول
بالدبابات من بينها بولندا وهي واحده من
اثني عشر دوله وافقت على تسليم اوكرانيا
100 دبابه اليوبارد فور حصولها على موافقه
المانيا
من المانيا لنقل هذه الدبابات اعلم ان
الموضوع على يزال قيد الدراسه حيث تجري
الان مناقشات سياسيه مختلفه في واشنطن قال
مسؤول امريكي الى البيت الابيض حسن قراره
بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز وان
الاعلان الرسميه سيتزامن مع الموافقه
الرسميه لالمانيا فيما رفض البيت الابيض
تاكيده تلك التقارير اما الكريم فيرى بان
تسليم دبابات اليوبارد لاوكرانيا سيؤثر
على العلاقات الروسيه الالمانيه وان
علاقات موسكو مع الدول الغربيه تقف الان
عند ادنى مستوياتها حيث تعهدت موسكو برد
قاسم على امداد كيف بالاسلحه الثقيله
وعادت بتدميرها